okay all right can you hear me
okay good so uh first hi and welcome to
this talk and uh
that's a pretty presumptuous title isn't
it so come please everyone uh come and
see how I work with Jason right I'm very
self-conscious
um my name is
um I'm in an old software developer I've
been sort of programming for money for
for 20 years
um I work for the Norwegian labor and
Welfare Administration
uh and today I'd like to talk about I'd
like to talk about three things that
sort of pertain to working with Jason
first and foremost and the thing the
most important thing and that thing that
I'm going to use the most of my time on
is how can we sort of work with Json in
a simple way so simplicity
then I'm going to talk a little bit
about uh contracts so in particular
contracts as a means to be explicit
which is something that then again can
help us to achieve this goal of
simplicity
and finally I'm going to talk a little
bit about testing
um
yeah
uh sort of it's an important disclaimer
for me that there's there are going to
be no Advanced Techniques at all in this
talk
and I hope I made that uh clear in the
abstract for the talk because that's
sort of the contract between me as a
speaker and you as an audience
um I think I did but well we'll see
about that in fact it's sort of going to
be a talk about the opposite of Advanced
Techniques I'm going to argue that to
the extent possible we should try to
refrain from using Advanced Techniques
than when we're working with Json
and the reason for that is that we're
trying to aim for Simplicity
which are sort of at odds with each
other
um
so Jason
uh
in preparation for this talk this was
the first slide I I made
um and the reason for that is that
somehow
um we managed to turn working with Jason
into this sort of
complicated mess and I think we did so
in an effort to make it easy which is
kind of kind of a sad result
so there's there's an element of a
feeling like I'm all too old for for
working in this manner
um too old to sort of be chasing down
weird behavior in in code that handles
Json but even more importantly is that
you're too young for this right you
should not be spending time working on
weird behavior in adjacent serializers
right you shouldn't you should be doing
something more interesting than that
now uh I need to add one caveat
um
so this talk is about how we from my
experience how we typically work with
Json in.net right so working inside a
statically typed programming language
um if you work with a dynamically typed
programming language like JavaScript or
closure or something like that some of
the problems that I'm going to talk
about might seem sort of weird or quaint
to you even that if that is the case I
sort of
suggest that you sit back and sort of uh
enjoy your feeling of superiority and
smugness for a while uh savor it like
it's a piece of fine chocolate and let's
let's all hope that you don't choke on
it
um
so so the reason for for this entire
thing let's let's start with this
question is Jason a complicated thing
so if I create a scale from simple to
complicated
where should we put Json here
sit over here towards the simple end
is somewhere in the middle
or is it actually quite complicated
and to answer that let's let's go to
json.org I think that's what it's called
um and look at what Json really is
right so uh Json value
can be one of these things it might have
some white space and stuff then it might
be either a string or it could be a
number
it could be an object it could be an
array and then it could be one of three
sort of uh constant values true false or
no
and that's sort of all there is to it
but of course um there are some details
here so a white space might be one of
these things it could be a space or line
field carries return horizontal tab
um a string a little bit more
complicated perhaps starts with a quote
and then could have basically anything
except a backslash or or another quote
and if you have a backslash then there
are some rules for what what characters
are allowed in that case and so on and
so forth this allows you to escape
characters in Json strings but still it
fits on the slide
ah then we have numbers and Json numbers
can be integers or decimal numbers and
it also supports scientific notation
objects
have these sort of like Curly bracket
things uh and it could be empty so it
just sort of degenerate uh objector can
have some properties and properties
have a Json string for a key and then it
has a colon and then it has another one
of these Json values
so it's recursive in that sense right
arrays even even simpler
um
bracket
could be an empty array or it could have
a comma separated list of values
and that that is Json
and from this I'm going to make the Bold
claim that Json is not complicated
it's actually very very simple it's hard
to imagine in fact to have a format that
you can go very much further to in the
direction of simple
right
uh you would put put something like like
yaml uh in an entirely different place
on this on this scale
right the yaml specification for yaml
1.11 in the PDF format is 86 pages that
is more complicated than Jason Jason is
simple
ah what about the code for handling
Jason
the code that we typically write to
handle Json
let's invent another scale from trivial
to non-trivial
and I'm talking now uh about the sort of
the mental effort you need to work out
exactly how it works
would you put it here
no
really put it somewhere towards a
non-trivial end and if you do that why
would you put it over there
when Jason is simple is it because
performance reasons
because performance is sort of a valid
concern always right so if you have like
gigabytes of Json documents coming at
you a hundred times a second maybe you
need to do something uh to make sure
that that's that's a fast process and
maybe you should be looking at some
other formats than Json also but but
that's a sort of uh another problem if
you do make your Json handling code
more towards the non-trivial end to
achieve performance I would uh highly
recommend measuring and making sure that
you actually get the performance
benefits that you think you're doing
um
if on the other hand
the purpose for making the code or the
whole process of handling Json
non-trivial is to eliminate some
boilerplate code
then we're going to have a conversation
now first when you eliminate boilerplate
code
you don't really get rid of the
boilerplate code you just move it
somewhere else right so you get rid of
the body but the spirit still lives
somewhere right
and it lives specifically inside some
Library some magic box that does some
meta programming to do the same job that
your boilerplate code is doing
so let's talk a little bit more about
boilerplate is boilerplate complicated
on a scale from trivial to non-trivial
where should we put boilerplate
well at least boil a plate for handling
Jason
is so far towards the trivial side
um it's so brain dead and so repetitive
that it's sort of an insult to our fine
Minds to be typing it out
that's how trivial boilerplate is
now there are some benefits to trivial
code
right let's talk about the benefits of
trivial code
first of all it's trivial
that's basically the main advantage but
trivial code then is easy to read it's
easy to test it's easy to change
and it's fairly trivial to spot and fix
mistakes it doesn't get much easier than
fixing mistakes in boilerplate code that
means that anyone can work on it you
don't need any special knowledge you
don't don't need a lot of experience to
do that there are no hidden workings no
different special dependencies that can
come out and bite you
and that means that there's little fear
also
when you change something of introducing
some weird bug
and if you do introduce a bug it's
fairly oddly obvious what the cause of
that bug was
okay so there's a famous talk by Rich
hickey uh Rich hickey is the inventor of
the closure programming language it's
called Simple Made Easy and in that talk
well he
distinguishes then between simple and
easy right that's
fairly obvious from the title and it
talks about what it means to be simple
what it means to be easy how we tend to
confuse though through those two things
and why that's a problem
and according to hickey apparently he
was looking out sort of the uh the
history of the word simple and it means
not intertwined with something else
right not mixed up with something else
just one thing
and we find sort of the same thing uh in
different kinds of advice and principles
and software engineering like the single
responsibility principle that says this
there should be one reason to change and
you tend to get that when things are not
mixed together right
there's also
um the old sort of uh design advice for
Unix tools that says that tools should
do one thing well sort of the same idea
now the opposite of simple is
complicated
and complicated that that means that
things are intertwined right not just
one thing you're doing several things at
once
easy on the other hand means something
entirely different easy means that it's
convenient it's close at hand
and it can feel very convenient to do
multiple things at once right
we have sayings like to kill two birds
with one stone
very nice
uh
now unfortunately I think we like to say
that we like simple code right
we say simple but unfortunately we often
mean easy
we say that we like simple code but we
tend to choose convenient code
and that means also that we tend to
choose magic over transparency and
making things explicit
now what does all this have to do with
Json
well one thing is that the authors of
Json serializer libraries they know know
all of this stuff they know that we
appreciate convenience
and therefore many Json serializer
optimize for convenience
many Jason serializers are way too
ambitious they want to help us too much
that's a strange thing to say but it's
actually a problem that you're trying to
do too much for us
of course at this point you may be
thinking what the hell is this guy
talking about
um but but to answer that let's sort of
um drill into exactly what this process
of Json serialization really is what's
sort of the essence of it right
well I made a drawing it's something
like this right it's actually a two-way
process so either you have some sort of
data structure in memory and you want to
convert that into a string
representation in the Json format that
is the Json serialization when we talk
about Json serialization we also tend to
include deserialization the
serialization which is going in the
opposite direction that means that you
have some Json
formatted string thing
and you want to sort of tokenize and
parse that and turn it into one of these
data structures in memory
of these two processes um
deserialization tends to be the hardest
one
uh yes now is this difficult to do
is it simple since we'll be talking
about Simplicity well the answer is it
depends and I mean it's not necessarily
super simple because anytime you're
parsing something it's not necessarily
super simple but it doesn't have to be
super complicated either
so I'm even going to say that it's going
to depend a lot
it's going to depend a lot in particular
on that data structure right we didn't
specify what that data structure was and
how that now relates to the Json text
you have
so let's take a look at this figure
again and see if we can make it more
explicit
we can sort of split it up a little bit
further into something like this right
so you have your data structure on the
one hand
then you have some sort of mapping
towards sort of like a conceptual
adjacent object model right it doesn't
necessarily have to exist in your
program but conceptually you're going to
sort of map it over to the Json object
model
and then you still realize that which is
sort of like a mechanical process
and then it goes the other way around as
well
now uh gets even worse than this in a
sense because now I'm doing this
um I'm assuming that I'm just having one
data structure but in a practical uh
situation it might be that you have one
producer of Jason and you have another
that's the consumer so we now do map
over to the conceptual model and then
you map to some other data structure
um
but to sort of simplify the diagram to
simplify the discussion a little bit I'm
going to pretend that we're always going
to deal with um
the same data structure now we have
on I guess the right hand side the
process of serialization a pure
serialization if you will on the right
so let's look a little bit about that in
in detail so you have the pure
serialization this problem has some very
nice properties
first of all it's a well-defined problem
we know exactly what goes into this
it means it sort of captures the
essential complexity of serializing in
these serialization
um from from text from from text in the
Json format and that means it also has a
bounded complexity right there are no
outside sources of additional complexity
to solving this problem the only thing
that can really add any complexity here
is if the Json format itself changes in
some way
and that happens rarely
it has a minimum of failure modes so
basically okay probably some computers
can always fail right but apart from
that what what can happen not a whole
lot right if the text happens not to be
adjacent then it's going to fail that's
okay but as long as it's actually valid
Json you're going to be able to
deserialize it into an object model for
the Json
um data format
now it's sort of an interesting
engineering challenge to turn this
process into something that's uses
little memory uh and is it's blazingly
fast and this is sort of a problem that
you want all the clever programmers in
the world to sort of compete to achieve
in the best possible way right and then
you can use their their refined results
to do that
okay
let's look at what sort of remains now
the mapping from the data structure to
today's an object model
what sort of characterizes this problem
what kind of problem is this
is sort of like a general arbitrary data
mapping situation from one data
structure to another
and unless you know something about that
data structure that you're sort of
trying to map to and from you don't know
how the hardest problem is so it has
some unfortunate properties
it's very different from the pure
serialization problem
so it's ill-defined first of all there
are a lot of open questions here because
we don't know what that data structure
is
you don't know if there's going to be
some sort of impedance mismatch that's
going to make this process hard
maybe there's going to be some
information loss going in one or the
other direction
maybe there's some data transformation
going on
and all of these the answers to all
these questions May introduce new
failure modes new reasons for this to
fail
and in a sense this problem has
unbounded complexity you can make this
arbitrarily hard but I'm sort of moving
the data structure far away from from
what the Json object model
talks about
now in a situation like this I'm going
to argue that you want direct control
over what happens
right you want maximum transparency you
want to know do you be able to inspect
exactly what's going on in this mapping
process that means you need explicit
code
but let's say let's say you don't do
that let's say you opt out of having
explicit code because that's boilerplate
and it's boring
and you decide to do to use some library
to do that mapping magically for you
what happens then
well that mapping process is going to
have to rely on heuristics and guesses
that's how it can do its magic right
it's going to assume some things about
this process it's going to rely on names
and conventions and stuff like that
and of course because heuristics can be
wrong it might offer sort of a broad set
of them and you can choose between them
so you have some configurations options
and then you might be able to provide
like hints and stuff and guidance to the
in addition to these heuristics for the
cases when it doesn't really produce
what you want so you can annotate your
your target data structure if you like
um
to help the library achieve
um what it was supposed to achieve
automatically right of course this now
couples you
and your data structure to whatever
Library you're using
and finally if all else fails
um you may be able to write some plugins
for your uh serializer Library
um that sort of fits into this larger
magic Machinery that you're relying on
and of course to write one of these
plugins that requires quite a lot of
in-depth knowledge about the library
you're using right and I I've tried to
write some of these plugins and it's not
trivial whatever it is it's not trivial
code right it usually has mistakes in it
because I'm not an expert on that magic
machinery
but all of these are sort of mechanisms
now to regain some of the control that
we lost when we said that this is going
to be handled magically for us
and as always I'm going to feel a little
bit like this right trying to control
you're going to have some buttons and
some levers try to pick up that thing
and and sort of achieve your goal that
way but it's always going to be a black
box and much more cumbersome and just
sort of reaching your hand and grabbing
what you want
let's talk
I'd like to say a few more words about
sort of writing these plugins because
I've gone down this road right
now one of the problems is that when
you're writing a plugin to a parser
you're writing a parser
and writing a parser can be a lot of fun
I think writing a parser is fun
especially when it doesn't have to work
that well writing a parser can be
educational
you can learn a lot from it
it's a nice cutter to do if you do it on
your free time that's cool
uh but whatever it is it's not simple
writing a parser is never simple even
for something as simple as Json it's not
trivial to get it correct and it's not
simple code right parser code is not
going to be trivial
and finally
writing a parser is probably not in your
core domain
right this is probably not why you're
hired as a programmer to be writing a
parser
and it might be that you should invest
your time and your effort and your
brilliant mind on something more
important
okay so let's let's return to this
ill-defined problem
what should we do in this situation
and one thing is that you can eliminate
this process altogether and just work
with the Json object model that's one
choice
and it's not as bad as you might think
but of course
that means that there might be um sort
of this you need an explicit
representation of the Json object model
somewhere in your code
either from the library you're using or
you're going to have to write that to
yourself
and you might not think that's a very
good idea so what you can do instead
and that I recommend doing is to use a
minimal mapping
you could avoid
um right
[Music]
um
you're going to avoid a lot of problems
if you try to you can have this mapping
but you make it as sort of as trivial as
possible and one way to do that is to
use something that I like to call the
Json dto so dto is a data transfer
object Json dto is one that sort of
specifically tailored to represent Json
data
that means there's going to be no
transformation of data here no
configuration
except it might be if you have an over
ambitious Json serializer you might have
to turn some things off
that might be your configuration I'm
going to come back to that later
no annotations on these Json details
because they won't be needed and you're
definitely not going to write any
plugins
and this I think
is a process that is okay to automate
right because you solved you answered a
lot of those open questions in the
simplest possible way
so for this process now we're going to
leave this right hand side to the Json
serializer and it's going to solve a
well-defined problem
and that means that you can take
whatever Jesus Jason serializer have you
have and if a brand new super fast uh
zero allocation Json serializer comes
along it's going to be very trivial to
swap it right because it's gonna it's
gonna solve exactly the same problem
right so now the sort of the Json
standard is going to be the contract
that these Json serializers act upon not
with every list of features they happen
to support
and then this
is going to be handwritten and yes I
know that this is going to sound oh man
I'm gonna have to write all this sort of
trivial mapping code that's exactly the
point
right
one of the nice things about handwriting
this also is that if there are tiny
minute variations inside of this
boilerplate code it's trivial to do that
whereas instructing your a sort of a
magic box to do that is much much harder
okay
and now you're also free to let these
sort of data structures you have be
actual genuine domain objects without
concern of how hard it is for the Json
serializer to actually be able to
serialize into your domain objects right
you don't have to sort of fight have
this battle so oh am I going to
encapsulate this but then it's going to
be harder for today's in serializer but
proper domain objects should be
encapsulated and so on and so forth
you're going to sort of sidestep all of
that and just take manual control
okay so so what exactly are these Json
DDOS that I talk about
so dto data transfer object um
but it's going to be some additional
constraints to make
um working with Json
extra simple
now they're going to be just property
bags
sort of typed property bags
now Json objects themselves are sort of
the untyped property bags right so like
dictionaries almost
um Json details are typed property bags
they have a default Constructor makes it
very easy to sort of create for the
serializer it has Getters and Setters
and then it can and this is sort of the
crucial part that makes it specific for
Json is you can only use types that have
some sort of direct counterpart in Json
now what I mean by that well I mean that
we can use strings
dot net strings mapped to Json strings
right
you can use integers and doubles because
they're mapped naturally to numbers in
Json
you can use whenever you have a Json
object you can use another one of these
Json dtos
and then for arrays you can use arrays
that's the only collection type you're
going to use in a dto no lists no I read
only list no collection no none of that
stuff just an array right
because you're gonna you're gonna know
in advance uh how how long that thing is
and they're never gonna append to it
stuff like that um
and finally you have a pool that's going
to cover Through unfolds and of course
null is the the absence of one of these
objects or race I guess
did you notice that there was no date
time here
there are no date times
in Json details and the reason for that
is that Jason has no concept of time we
didn't see any date times in the sort of
the specification for Jason the Jason is
all just a string it happens to have
some sort of format that's a detail that
Jason doesn't care about
and you might be sitting there thinking
surely we should be making an exception
for time times are so important we have
a lot of time stamps it is so boring to
do all this mapping by hand surely
no
and actually I'm going to double down
and say hell no
because this is the siren Call of
convenience this is easy we want to use
it because it's there right newtonself
does this for us it's so easy to use it
but easy is not the same as simple
and we know that from experience that we
get time wrong all the time
in fact I'd like to show you an example
see if I can make this
this work
I have some code here can you read this
okay
so this is some code
um it uses the newton-soft Newton soft
is sort of the most popular Json
serializer Library in.net it has
probably more downloads than sort of
atoms in the known universe everyone
uses newtonsoft
um I'm going to try here so the the
point here is that I'm going to try to
well
I have this Json text
that represents an object and that
object has one property called the
timestamp
and it contains a timestamp right a
format it time step inside a string
and I'm going to deserialize that into a
j object with this sort of like Newton
soft representation
for the Json object model
and then I'm I have to go versus I'm
going to pick out the timestamp and I'm
going to write both things to the
console
very easy right
um let's see I'm going to try
to run this code now
see where we are
yeah I have my daytime console thing.net
how do you do this
thing.net developers please help me uh
something like this right I'm going to
execute this code hopefully it works
and now we can see what was outputted
what happened to my string
I had a string here
it says very clearly what the string is
and then I picked out the string and I
got this
now I can turn this off this Behavior
this is Newton's off trying to help me
right because it tries to parse it sees
that it's oh it actually is a daytime
thing and then it does something to it I
don't know where sort of my offset
information got to and why it sort of
reformatted everything and I don't care
I don't want to have to figure it out
so yeah we get we get time wrong all the
time let's see
I'm gonna
try to return to my presentation now
and sort of the lesson here
is that whenever you're surprised by
some Behavior you should make it
explicit
whenever you're surprised by some
Behavior we should get rid of all the
magic
we should choose control we need to know
exactly what's going on so so there's
nothing to figure out
because it's right there
now okay so um speaking of surprises
you know that bugs are the name we use
for surprises right and where else can
we find bugs
except then in in non-trivial code that
changes or in code that deals with time
we tend to find from my experience at
least we tend to find bugs in between
systems right and system boundaries also
often correspond to team boundaries
which means that usually there are some
people that are going to have to
communicate for things to work well and
of course we know communication never
goes well
there are always misunderstandings right
it's inevitable so you find bugs in the
integration at the borders of our
systems
and what sort of the lingua Franca that
we tend to use at Borders
well it's our friend Jason again isn't
it
um of course often
not always I guess but often we want it
not just to be Jason it's not enough
that it's sort of application slash Json
usually we want it to be the right Jason
we have some assumptions about the data
being passed from one system to another
right
so you have some sort of communication
situation using Json from system a to
system B and I don't really care in this
situation whether that's a web API or if
there's some sort of message on a
message but something like that it
doesn't really matter in this context
system a sense adjacent document to
system B Because system B needs it
sometimes there's a problem with this
Json document
and when that happens
from my experience what what tends to to
happen is that there is a message on
Slack
the integration broke did you change
anything
this is going to be the system B people
going to the system a slack Channel and
say this integration broke did you
change something in your system and in
particular this question that I've seen
so many times
have you changed your Json serializer
config
how is your serializer configured we
have set it up so and so perhaps you
could use the same configuration so that
it's going to match
there's going to be this this sort of
frantic uh looking for whatever it was
that changed right either system a
changed
or maybe system B changed or maybe the
data changed and we saw some data that
we never saw before
or maybe it was just that the Unlucky
timing in the sense that we hit one of
our timing bugs
and I am done with these discussions
I'm never having them ever again
because we don't need to be having these
kinds of discussions
the only question that we need to ask is
what does the contract say
right
we need some sort of contract that
answers all these questions or or
specifies what the json's document is
going to be looking like right and
without a contract you're going to have
sort of an informal contract that's
going to be all the documents that ever
pass through this integration before and
didn't break it
and who knows what that set of documents
is
it might not even be a consistent set of
documents because probably in the
meantime both systems have changed
it might not be the same contract
anymore so what do you do in that
situation
well what typically happens is that you
change one or both of the systems to
make the integration work again and then
you then you wait for a while
Until It Breaks again for the same
reason and you have the same slack
message coming and I am done with this
process also
I I'm not going to work like this
anymore that I don't think you should
either
I have done it for too long so instead
we need a contract to answer these
questions for us right and we need to be
precise what it means uh for a Json
document to be valid right we need some
sort of agreement between system a and
system B
system a and system B are going to have
to have some sort of conversation to
Define what valid means right and that
might be painful or difficult but that's
sort of where the value add is right
that we actually managed to describe it
I never want to hear anyone ask about
the Json serializer config ever again
and the reason is that it's an
implementation detail I don't care what
you do I don't care how you do your
decision serialization right I would
recommend that you use the simple
transparent process with as little magic
as you as you can but I don't really
care all I really care about is whether
or not you uphold the contract
so when whenever the integration breaks
now you can ask well is the document
valid according to the contract
if it is then the problem with the
system B if it's not then the problem
with system a
so Json schema is the format that I like
to use to create contracts
if I have a web API I'm going to use
open API for that which is sort of
at least in recent uh versions it's sort
of Json schema with the additional
ability to specify what the endpoints
are under result codes are going to be
and so on and so forth uh four sort of
um
more asynchronous uh things message
queues and so on and so forth I like to
use async API which is sort of the same
similar to open API
and that means that when we have this
communication between system a and
system B we don't just send a Json
document over and hope for the best we
have some sort of schema that we can use
to validate whether or not that Json
document is actually any good
that allows us to to shift the
conversation to discussing what the
contract says instead of the system
internals
and this is what it means to program to
an interface like
we like we like to think that we program
two interfaces this is what it means
that you have a contract and then then
you sort of discuss that
and it's important to note that a
contract is not the same as
documentation often we think that well
okay we just need to document this we
need to document it so that someone else
can work with it but a contract is
something more it's an agreement right
it's something that we agreed upon
that's going to be valid for our for our
communication
and in in that context I'm going to have
to talk about say a few words about
review reverse engineering contracts
because this is something that we like
to do we use tools like swashbuckle or
something like that
um to produce documentation
um
it's like you have a running server and
then you have some tool that does
reverse engineering on that running
server to derive a contract
uh in the case of swashbuckle is going
to produce an open API specification and
I'm really impressed that they can do
this at all so there's some magnificent
work done in swashbuckle to be able to
do this and sort of in awe of that
accomplishment
and it's also very easy to do right
you can just turn it on you download the
new get package and boom you have open
API specification
while I'm mightily impressed that it's
possible to generate a valid open API
specification in this way
never do it
never exploit that power
and there are a couple of reasons for
that first is that a contract really
needs to be sort of a first class
versioned artifact you need to be able
to go to contract
and see what it says and you can't have
the situation where the API is down so
now you have no contract and you don't
know what it is
because it was derived at runtime right
can't be this ephemeral thing
and what's even more important that how
you happen to behave today is not a
contract that's not how contracts work
so if I rent an apartment from you
and then sort of um how much I I
determine that I should be paying this
month is going to be our contract you're
not going to be happy with that right
you're going to say that's not something
that I want to be our contract that if I
want to pay you like uh
a thousand dollars one month and then
I'll go well I don't feel like paying a
thousand dollars next month so I'm going
to pay 500 you're not going to be happy
with that
and again an implementation this is sort
of the same statement and implementation
is not an interface I well you should
never say things like this but I don't
think in most cases that we would do
this at the code level to sort of
automatically have some tool to generate
an interface for every class and include
all the public members of course someone
has probably done this but but that's
not what an interface means right
and for this you need to write this
contract by hand and yes this means
again you're going to have to write
something that you might find tedious
and that you might have created some
approximation
to using an automated tool
I'm going to make a bold statement that
handwritten contracts are much higher
quality than whatever you're able to to
reverse engineer from your running
server
of course it's going to be disconnected
so it might go out of sync and people
are terrified of this
but it's going to be much much higher
quality
of course
um you can say that well I can I can
always write a plugin to my sort of
reverse engineering tool and have used
that to write sort of arbitrarily good
contracts using my plugin
right and you can uh pull in information
extra additional information using
attributes or whatever and I've gone
down this route as well
it's definitely not trivial code
you're going to have bugs your contract
is probably going to be something else
than what the server actually does
so it's probably going to be a mismatch
anyway
and anyway
um we don't want to be spending our time
doing this and there is no way that
you're gonna sort of do this work as
quickly as I can just type the contract
by hand I'm going to sort of be running
at normal speed you're going to be
trying to be running underwater
backwards
right I can do this much faster I can
iterate much faster on it
and also you want to use that contract
this first class versioned artifact as a
collaboration tool with whoever uses
your service
right
you want ideally to be co-designing the
contract
right sitting with them and typing it
out trying different solutions you can't
do that easily if you the way that
you're working with it is through some
sort of opaque reverse engineering
process
because then you need to actually
implement the stuff before you have a
contract
have shared ownership of this contract
and that makes for better contracts
okay ah so that was contracts um
finally I'd like to mention a little bit
about testing
now when you sort of decouple your
contract for from your implementation
that means that you open up the
possibility that there is a mismatch
right so you're going to need some sort
of test for schema validation
and this of course you might find boring
to write
um there's a tool there's not a whole
lot of choice for schema validators in
the not net space that I was able to
find but there is a tool you can use
that's called J and Json schema and has
a nice uh scheme of validation support
it also tries to be very convenient so
it has a lot of other stuff too don't
use it
um
okay just to show you how that might
look like let's see if I can
find my validation tests
right so this is a very simple test I
have a Json document and I have a schema
for that document let's see if I can
find them uh over here validation test
this is my oh
let's see
oh let's actually have it like that
that's fine it doesn't matter
um so I have two books here I have a
decent document with two books
uh and they look fairly similar
um
that's okay and I have my let's see what
my schema looks like this is my Json
schema now it says that I have well
an object this is sort of the root
element or the root uh value rather and
it says that it's required to have a
books property that books property is
going to be an array and each item in
that array is going to look like this
that's going to have actually let's
start with this right
I'm not going to have any additional
properties you can tweak these things in
in Json schemas you can say okay I'm
going to expect to have an ID and a
title and an author I'm going to require
those to be there and but it's fine to
have additional properties right
oh not in this case when I turn it off
um okay and so I have also here
the ability to say that okay my ID is
going to be a string but it's also going
to have to satisfy this pattern which is
a regular expression and the title is
going to be a string but it can only be
tops 100 characters
so let's let's try to run this now let's
see if it works
so I can do.net test
how is it going to fare
well it didn't go so well
it has a couple of problems
the array item was not valid on the
first book and it says that it's not
allowed to have additional properties
and it found this addition property that
shouldn't be there
uh let's see
yeah that's that's going to be this this
property here right
but actually in order to um not be
overly restrictive it might be okay to
have these additional properties so I
can just say okay I'm going to allow
that it doesn't really matter as long as
I get the data I need today that's fine
it might be that in some future version
it's going to be uh mandatory to have
this Edition thing
uh let's see and how does that affect
things
right so now I got rid of that but it
still says that the title is too long
and that's because I sort of
mess things up over here right this is
this is kind of strange they can get rid
of that
and now everything is fine
okay so that's that's a tool you can use
um for for validating your schema
uh finally
I'd like to talk about some tests for
expected Json content sometimes quite
often I guess it's not enough to verify
that uh that the data is valid According
to some schema sometimes you want to
know that you got exactly the Json
content that you that you requested
um it might be that you're writing tests
for for your own web API or something
like that so how do you do that
comparison
so you sort of have two choices right
either you compare them as strings
and that's problematic but because it's
much too low level in a sense because
you're looking just at individual
character instead
um maybe your comparison can say well
there's something in this Json document
that has uh thousands of characters at
sort of position 285 there's a
discrepancy
and now you sort of okay I'm gonna have
to look out uh look up uh character
number 285 and look see if I can find
out
uh what's wrong
and because that's sort of very low
level information just captures the
first error that you find
right because it stops there
some people turn to sort of comparing
objects instead so they create they sort
of derive this data structure maybe they
use their Json dtos or something like
that these Theory lies through the
response and then you have some expected
Json response and you deserialize that
as well and then you do the comparison
that's sort of you can do that but it's
sort of indirect and clumsy right
because you're not really comparing the
Json documents you're comparing
something that you derived from them of
course if you have sort of this minimal
mapping to the Json details the the
distance isn't going to be great but
still and there's also the thing
um
that by default uh dot net objects have
uh reference equality right so if you
want to compare structure instead of of
seeing that is actually the exact same
object you're going to have to implement
value equality for your Json dtos
that is boring code that is super boring
code and it's even needless code right
uh you might be able to rely on some
test Library magic for this to sort of
implement using reflection uh value
equality for your objects
um I saw that was
at least there's been discussions in
shouldley if they should support this
right
but it's solving the wrong problem in a
sense what you're trying to do is
compare Json text right you're trying to
compare text but with the knowledge that
is actually valid Json
and because
um I couldn't find any tool that does
this in.net
I I had to write them myself
there is a tool called quibble
and it has also a sort of companion tool
called quibble.x Unit that you can use
from your X unit tests to use quibble
and it purpose of quibble is to sort of
have this json-aware string comparison
it's a very simple tool but I'd like to
show it to you
let's see
um that was my validation tests I don't
need that
okay so actually let's let's do this one
and I'm going to skip this one
I don't know
okay so I have again
a Json document let's see if I can find
it
these are my contact texts
this is going to be my expected Json
result looks a bit similar to the
example we had before
and I'm going to compare that
to this
and at a quick glance maybe you can sort
of catch that there is something that's
not entirely the same but let's try to
run quibble um
yep
ah can't type
okay that didn't work so well uh there
were some uh mismatches
um let's see what quibble tells us here
well first of all it lists both the
expected and the actual Json document
that it got but it also says
specifically that it found two
differences
first it found a mismatch in the first
book and it says that it found this
additional property Edition
and it also says that it was a problem
with uh with a string in the author
property here in the second book it
expected Leo brought it but it was Chuck
Moore that's obviously wrong for for
this book right
um thinking forth which is actually
written by Leo Brody uh uh Chuck Chuck
Morris of course the author of fourth
the language itself right easy to mix it
up
um but it's it's a mistake that you want
to catch
now of course just looking at these two
at least two uh Json documents you would
probably be able to say okay I can I can
do this by manual inspection it's not
that hard right
but of course real life Json documents
rarely look like this real life Json
documents tend to look something more
like let's see
like this right
there's a lot of stuff there
and when I compare that to my expected
thing well there's a lot of stuff there
too and it's not so obvious where the
differences are if there are any
so let's try that also
um
okay let's see I should be
removing oh this is the wrong thing
again
so same kind of test
um just Compares really exactly the same
thing it just uses a different
um
different Json document
so I'm trying to run that
sorry
uh
oh
that's unfortunate
uh
thanks
okay try to run again
see what happens
now
again
there was some mismatch
but because the OB sort of the the
documents themselves are so large this
is getting a lot more useful now so it
says that it has four differences and
exactly what they are is not that
important uh but it's sort of the
important point that it points you
exactly where in the Json document there
was a problem
so uh I think quibble is useful if you
work with Json in.net I hope you might
too
um
okay so finally let's go through the
summary now
first my please just please let Jason be
simple Sim Jason is simple don't write
uh complicated code to work with
something that simple
avoid all these needless Magic
and don't write a Json parser unless you
absolutely have to and make sure if you
think you have to make sure that you
actually have to
Json serializer should just serialize
Jason that's all they should do by
default
Json documents are going to need a
contract
an explicit contract we should stop
discussing internal details when
something goes wrong when we exchange
Json documents we should write these
contracts by hand because it makes for
much better contracts and it also makes
for much better collaboration practices
we should validate that our Json
documents are actually valid
and finally we should use quibble to
compare Json documents as Json
thank you
[Applause]
oh I forgot to say are there any
questions
one question
okay so uh the question was
um
a lot of people complain when the system
text Json was released that it wasn't as
convenient as newtonsoft and
um
what can I say about that uh I can say
that
that complaint obviously stems from the
fact that we've gotten used to all these
conveniences from newtonsoft my Approach
would be uh to sort of sidestep the
problem altogether by letting Newton
soft do as little as possible and then
let system text Jason do the exact same
job right it shouldn't be sort of this
mismatch and the pain then of converting
from Newton's off to system text Json is
caused by the fact that we used all
these conveniences
any other questions
there's a question up there
so you said uh what do you feel about
Auto generating Json dtos
um using some Tool uh from from a
contract something like that or so
generating uh from the contract into
details
um my position on that is that I
probably wouldn't do it myself because I
prefer actually writing it uh but it's
an implementation detail in a sense as
long as you have the contract I don't
really care how you'd how you author
your code in that in that respect so
um but from my experience often
um
well first of all there are things that
are hard to generate things that you can
express in Json schema for instance that
are not that don't really map over that
well to to the.net type system there are
things that are going to be lost
on the way and then there might be
things that you want to re-add
afterwards and whenever you have this
it's going to generate something that's
almost what I want but not completely
then you're sort of in a paint spot
right so
yeah
any other questions
oh well uh further's out there
right so so the question was uh in XML
there's this uh xslt transformation that
allows you to
um transfer from one XML uh format or a
document to another one and you have
something similar and Json is that the
question or
to HTML
right right so not necessarily to
another XML document but to to something
else right to whatever
right
um
I'm not aware of any
any tool that has uh
uh
broad acceptance that does that for
Jason
and should there be I I don't know so I
don't really have uh
a comment beyond that so perhaps if you
want that capability use XML instead of
Json using XML is just fine right so I
transforming from
okay so transforming from Json to XML
and then you can use the style sheet I
would ideally then uh don't produce
Jason in the first place Just Produce
XML if you can of course it's another
system I don't know probably they're
going to be some point pain points but
that but I I have no personal experience
trying that approach so yeah
yeah yes another question
okay so the question was um
what if Json schema doesn't have support
that allows you to express the
constraint that you want on your
contract is that
I don't know I haven't been in that
situation myself I would say probably uh
sorry
right so maybe there are some sort of uh
whatever value you have over here should
also match some value over here or
something like that I think
as long as you don't have sort of
um support in in the tool that you're
the in the specification that you're
using for your contract you're going to
have to resort to writing it down in the
contract as free text as you can add
constraints like that just by by typing
it out in natural language that's that's
my best I don't have anything beyond
that
so how are we on time
redone or
one minute is there a short last
question
preferably one where I can say no
okay I think we're just gonna leave it
at that thank you
[Applause]